статуя коло вчив перед нікуди обличчя будемо
чи єврокомісію брюсселем рішення просто
анти проти Росії через і дієго сирії
так вже за вислугу палітрі серед лідерів у
ліс на моїй області фокіним а на думку з
пострига че в росії за коло вид провід
дружині ще дано нові ксанті
квіти мускарі звідки ногу в брюсселі
і зняв і самим гуворо неможливо в
данії сансе один з основних
інструментів піску ясно росію поважають
експерти
exo секретар європейської служби за
зовнішньополітичну діяльність та п'єр
він також за артою уваги і нас ризику
карту за його слова мої та зможемо
розгадати російського з ризику бомбарду
ваней алеппо я козла дуже профілю
dynasty
ту ж волосінь ви слова лівані я був
порубаний міністром та закордонних довідки
з ними вже говорити про віч до викладені в
чим може відкритий шлях до судового
процесу це важливо мати на уазі ic1
виклали мт позов на руси you sure це
чи може ви ксантії розширення списку
осі по при чесних людей, крім у
серії
яким забув рунету висту з гравцем яких
заморозити на території євросоюзу
ми ж вами заходи може тусуватися і
шинкою голові росії в цьому води на
лікарі будуть сквало не на відбувається
проблеми з брекситу ми ними краса щур
та капах етнологи descrying євросоюзу
ваша experts харчування з рекорд і нелюд
теж у брюсселі найму вірності США на
троянди виборі в yoba майки завершую по
саду в дружини травня на лижних of clay вам і
вікна слідок руси це асад виграють годину
вона відразу колибу тримай новий президент
США і вага буде більшою області башар
асад може взяти алеппо та контролю вати
2 найбільших місця сирі та алепо та
таким чином росія зможе
диктувати
умова для перемир'я у житті своїх
позицій для право джинена на їх санкцій
проти Росії за ідею сиру і потрібно
склепіння всіх 28 краї нічого не vs вода
сепак і на ви статтям цього прогнозу
this спирт з парне показує і розбитий
на стілець і в союзі харчуванням про багато
санте в брюсселі пожертвують на користі
володіють
компромісним рішенням стану їх не є
продовження перерізу 2017 з год на пи в
руку